on s'est rendu compte que dans les
sessions d'aspiration on voit que dans
les aspirateurs traditionnel madame à
des problèmes pour pouvoir aller aspirer
la poussière sous le canapé elle va
devoir se baisser cd c'est très très bas
pour aller le plus loin possible
la session d'aspiration durant à peu
près en moyenne 20 à 30 minutes
elle va devoir se baisser peu seront
probablement une vingtaine de froid et
oui alors c'est un déferlement vous avez
bien sûr ce qui dérange ingérable
émaillé oui mais moi ça m'a fait
vraiment rire et masculine madame c il
s'adresse qu'aux par madame c'est la
liesse que les femmes car il y avait
forcément des indignés de circonstance
dans les réseaux sociaux va ouvrir mais
ça très drôle et ya aucun souci circulez
rien avant on veut quoi on veut que ce
monsieur démissionne on veut que rowenta
qu'est donc la marque face un communiqué
pour qui s'excitent se sont excusés
c'est véridique se sont alors hissés aux
excuses et rowenta bataillon dire aux
jeunes dit il marque qui s'adresse à
tous les consommateurs
la séquence diffusée ce soir est un
extrait d'un tournage plus long et coupé
qui ne reflète bien sûr pas les valeurs
portées par la marque vous savez famille
parce que même si c'est issu d'un
tournage plus longs ont pu couper la
phrase en elle-même elle est exécrable
c'est pas possible géraldine depuis les
années 60 la femme a s'est émancipé
quand même frange bien gérer les
rapports officiels adroit il blâme aussi
passé à ce but de relancer mais si tu
dis monsieur messier mais moi j'ai un
pote à moi ni femme d'affaires elle
s'appelle mike sûr que vous traiterez
ménages
ah oui voilà bah pourquoi pas s'adresser
en disant monsieur dame pourquoi madame
elle va faire ceci il aurait très bien
pu et bobonne a va passer
c'est la vidéo bien sûr que oui et après
on a une cocotte minute et après on a
une machine à laver
c'est ridicule il y dit que elle elle
madame l banon et moi et moi je trouve
qu'elle explique bien oui
tiffany voilà lé voilà donc c'est vrai
alors vous c'est quoi vos arguments
alors non mais moi c'était sur une si ce
n'est que j'ai vu cette phrase je me
suis dit ça y est on est bon tout le
monde va tomber dessus en disant phrase
sexiste oui on peut tout plus dire que
c'est une phrase maladroite mais soir
était de faire un débat d'idées sur tout
et devoirs du sexy spartoo écoeurant
ventas excuses sait-on que ces deux ne
l'achetez un signe rabat alors
honnêtement c'est